bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
la réforme territoriale qui va être
abordé à plusieurs reprises par les
sénateurs trois questions vont être
posées dont celle de l'ancien premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin pour le
groupe ump c'est le premier ministre
manuel valls qui devrait lui répondre
les groupes des radicaux de gauche et
les groupes et le groupe communiste vont
également interpellé le gouvernement sur
cette réforme territoriale annoncée est
précisé en début de semaine par le
président de la république parmi les
autres thèmes qui vont être abordés lors
de cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement liés à la
lutte contre le terrorisme avec
notamment de question de la sénatrice
écologiste esther benbassa mais
également du président de la commission
des lois jean pierre sueur qui est sur
notre plateau et qui va sans doute nous
en dire un petit mot dans quelques
minutes là encore manuel vals je crois
j'en perds soeur a prévu de vous
répondre cet après midi c'est des
questions qui feront suite bien sûr à ce
qui s'est passé le week-end dernier au
musée juif de
bruxelles et puis les mesures fiscales
vont également
être sans sont des questions qui vont
être posées au gouvernement alors qu'il
ya des questions qui se posent ces
derniers jours autour du pacte de
responsabilité le medef la cfdt semble
prendre leurs distances avec ce pacte de
responsabilité
on y reviendra également lors de cette
séance des questions d'actualité et puis
ensuite avec nos invités non on va
commencer par un point sur la
décentralisation c'est quand même la
grande réforme annoncée cette semaine
par le président de la république une
réforme qui a déjà été largement
commentée ici au sénat par les groupes
politiques par les présidents de région
les présidents de conseils généraux qui
sont nombreux au sénat on a sur notre
plateau avec nous en ce début d'après
midi d'abord eric doligé bonjour vous
êtes sénateur ump également président du
conseil général du loiret et puis dans
le même département donc jean pierre
sueur sénateur socialiste et président
de la commission des lois là en tant que
président la commission des lois jean
père sur bonjour quand ce texte autour
des régions va arriver en examen en
commission des lois ici au sénat et puis
après dans l'hémicycle on nous a dit en
juillet donc ce sera en juillet et une
première séance en commission et en
séance d'accord
donc ça c'est un délai relativement
court finalement oui on aborder cette
question très importante et qui tient au
coeur des sénateurs le j'espère qu'il y
aura de lecture dans chaque assemblée
ça me paraît nécessaire pour un texte de
cette importance est-ce que vous avez un
engagement du gouvernement sur ce point
si je vous dis mon espérance c'est que
je me suis renseigné auparavant pour ne
pas être déçu d'accord donc vous n'allez
pas être déçus eric doligé ça vous
rassure peut-être tout le monde et
notamment les français sont plutôt pour
ce regroupement de deux régions il ya
quand même une opinion dans une large
parc de favorable ce regroupement de
régions est ce que l'opposition ici au
sénat va avoir une position un petit peu
constructif sur ce dossier ce que vous
allez essayer d'avancer ensemble avec la
gauche jean pierre sueur par exemple non
mais on est très constructif dans
l'opposition la preuve c'est que l'on a
travaillé sur un rapport de manière
égalitaire entre la gauche et la droite
un rapport qui s'appelle le rapport
raffarin krattinger qu'à citer au moins
trois fois le premier ministre l'ancien
système même bien plus allez mettons 20
fois en disant que c'était la référence
des références sauf qu'il ne cite que la
moitié du rapport la diminution par deux
du nombre de régions question sur
laquelle on est tout à fait d'accord
mais il a oublié le maintien des
départements puisqu'il faut marcher sur
deux jambes les départements d'un côté
qui sont la proximité et les régions
diminué en nombre pour leur permettre
d'avoir une certaine taille donc nous si
l'on va sur le rapport krattinger
raffarin qui est notre bible et qui
devrait être la bible du premier
ministre après ce qui est dit à moins
qu'ils nous racontent des histoires ce
qui n'est pas possible bien évidemment
ne changent jamais d'avis quand on
gouverne un pays bas a priori on devrait
être d'accord mais c'est quand même
assez mal parti puisque aujourd'hui on
sent qu'on nous estimer à quel étage de
la fusée finalement
posée depuis longtemps mais vous savez
les fusées ça se recompose on a bien vu
que la fusée du mois de janvier n'était
pas la même que celle du mois d'avril
qui n'est pas la même que celle du mois
de juin donc d'ici le même si le
gouvernement semble
qui me fait plaisir c'est que jean
pierre sueur espère qu'il y aura deux
lectures espérons que cela sera la
réalité et si vous espérez qui est si
vous experts de lecture au parlement
jean pierre sueur ça veut dire que vous
espérez aussi un débat ouvert un débat
ouvert notamment mais oui aux
amendements
des sénateurs absolument et je vais vous
répondre sur les deux points que vous
avez évoqué perrine tarneaud premier
point les régions eux c'est une bonne
idée d'avoir des régions plus fortes
entre nous des régions plus forte c'est
pas forcément des régions plus vaste la
force d'une région ne tient pas la
superficie alors ça passe par quoi eh
bien ça passe par un débat parlementaire
puisque vous avez lu comme moi que le
président de la république a dit que la
carte qui a été publié était soumise au
parlement et que monsieur le premier
ministre a dit qu'il y aurait forcément
des évolutions dont nous avons eu le
même ministre qui est aussi fermé la
porte attendez a pleinement le droit
d'option sur certains de mes attentes et
d'une autre en savait que la loi elle
est faite par le parlement et nous avons
hérité avec eric doligé d'une région un
peu vaste qui commence dans
l'eure-et-loir et qui finit presque à
bordeaux il me semble qu'il ya d'autres
solutions moi je suis très attaché au
val de loire donc si vous voyez le graal
noir reviennent vers une région entre le
sens naturel mais écoutez on va discuter
et moi je ne considère pas que cette
carte soit prendre ou à laisser c'est un
sujet dont nous allons parler et et rien
n'est fini à cet égard ouais
deuxièmement pour ce qui est des
départements il y a eu un moment une
sorte d' accélération que j'ai trouvé
préjudiciable on nous a dit pratiquement
on va supprimer tout de suite les
départements moi j'ai pensé que c'était
absurde et je les dis d'ailleurs au
président de la république et ce qui a
été annoncé
c'est qu'on allait faire les élections
départementales en 2015 donnons-nous
cinq ans pour que les choses se passent
bien et que l'on voit les transmet les
compétences qui peuvent être transférées
aux régions aux communautés de communes
aux métropoles aux aux agglomérations
mais il ne faut pas faire cela dans la
précipitation et je propose qu'on en
parle calmement et sereinement eric
doligé est comme jean pierre sueur vous
allez vous opposez regroupement entre le
centre et le limousin d'abord je suis
heureux d'accueillir jean pierre sueur
dans l'opposition un donc ça me ferait
plaisir
la jolie plus de l'accueillir chose
quand même on a beaucoup mais je pense
qu'on est un petit à petit sur jean
pierre sueur ohlala chose mais c'est pas
facile c'est peut-être averses mais en
ce qui concerne bien évidemment le
limousin et poitou charentes c'est pas
notre attirance naturelle
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe tous
les matins dans l'orléanais puisque je
parle plutôt de la région du loiret et
d'orléans tout le monde vers le monde
vers paris vers le nord personne ne
descend vers le sud je pense qu'il y en
avait quand même habitée poitiers vous
êtes noir vous êtes maintenant à 1h30
tgv de paris aussi oui vous êtes à 1h30
de tgv de paris mais vous êtes à deux
heures de route d'orléans et puis il y
aura 5 140 km entre le nord et le sud de
la région c'est une assise des
regroupements de régions forcément non
séparation le principe on peut arriver à
trouver des régions qui ont une forme
homogène qui ont éventuellement une
métropole il aurait été bien que chaque
région est à la limite leur métropole
pour avoir un lieu d'attirance
écoutez là j'étais pas opposé c'était
pas ma tasse de thé comme vous dites
mais je n'étais pas opposé
comme l'a dit jean pierre sueur et un
instant d'aller plutôt vers l'ouest look
d'aller plutôt sur l'axé ligérien parce
qu'il y avait une certaine continuité
liés à la loire mais monter moi je les
dis depuis dix ans peut-être en avance
que de monter vers le nord et vers le
sud du bassin parisien avec les yvelines
et la seine et marne on à l'abri et la
beauce on a des secteurs ruraux on a des
secteurs industriels qui sont denses et
des secteurs de recherche à saclay qui
sont forcément aller vers des
départements plus riches bah écoutez
nous on nous dit nous dit on va vous
mettre avec les plus pauvres de manière
à vous appauvrir moi je dis je pour
manière à les enrichir oui enfin quand
on n'est pas très bien on n'arrive pas à
enrichir les paumes par contre quand on
n'est pas très riche mais qu'on n'est
pas trop mal comme nous sommes dans le
nord de la région lorsque l'on part avec
des régions dynamiques auquel on peut
apporter quelque chose je pense que tous
ensemble on peut tirer vers le haut
tirés vers le bas ça n'a aucun sens et
je pense que les régions telles qu'elles
ont été travaillées ont été travaillés
sur un plan purement politique et pas
sur un plan économique et de
développement c'est tout le travail
qu'on va avoir à faire pendant plusieurs
mois j'espère de très nombreux mois mais
quelles garanties jean persia vernement
que
perrine tarneaud c'est un point où je
suis en désaccord avec eric doligé
depuis longtemps mais je sais depuis
longtemps parce que eric doligé pense
finalement qu'on pourrait se raccrocher
à l'île de france ou à des départements
de l'île de france alors je tiens là
dessus à dire deux choses premièrement
mon respect et mon amitié pour le
pousser à centrer puis limousin et à
face avant ce sont de belles et
magnifique région du jean pierre sueur
renard mais non mais c'est pas mal des
jeux un j'assume deuxièmement ce serait
une erreur de faire une région par à ile
de france parce qu'on deviendrait une
grande banlieue ou une super périphérie
c'est la branche je suis toujours un
partisan du val de loire et je crois que
dans le schéma qui a été présenté il y a
de bonnes choses il y a des choses à
revoir c'est à ça que sert le parlement
alors on voit sur ces images que l'on
n'a vu manuel valls arrivé dans
l'hémicycle du sénat est là le président
du sénat jean-pierre bel également nos
classes et marées non vous avez encore
deux minutes je pense jean pierre sueur
on sent bien
ça va être très difficile de trouver une
majorité ici au sénat pour adopter ce
projet de loi autour de la refonte des
régions françaises mais on nous dit
c'est déjà cela pour les métropoles or
vous avez vu que grâce au sénat a promis
m la métropole de lyon celle du grand
paris est celle de marseille avait
toujours espoir de trouver mais moi je
suis une majorité je suis alors que
l'ump va s'opposer les centristes mais
on va les communistes haussier ce serait
pas mal de discuter avant de savoir si
on s'oppose ou si on ne s'oppose pas
vous trouvez pas que c'est ce qui est ce
que vous allez avoir suffisamment de
temps pour débattre de cette question et
si hassan à silwan arrivants gomis et
des vigiers comme je vous ai dit avant
la séance que c'était un grand partisan
de deux lectures c'est pour avoir le
temps nécessaire il faut que ça battures
dans un tribune publiée dans la presse
quotidienne régionale mardi matin le
président république évoque aussi la
question de l'intercommunalité ça a été
moins évoqués - débattu pour l'instant
avec une refonte du seuil pour
l'intercommunalité à vingt mille
habitants il ya déjà eu des
regroupements récente s'est parfois fait
dans la douleur d'imposer ce nouveau
seuil ça vous semble difficile et le
doligé moi je suis effaré parce qu'il ya
les régions les départements les
intercommunalités elles viennent d'être
élu il ya deux mois aujourd'hui on leur
dit c'est plus 5000 c'est plus dix mille
ça va être 20000 donc ça veut dire qu'on
va les faire exploser que ceux qui
viennent d'être élus dans deux ans parce
qu'on nous dit au 1er janvier 2010 est
insupportable allez je vous laisse merci
beaucoup le rac l'intercommunalité parce
qu'il ya aussi des choses à dire plus
tard avec plaisir et merci merci jean
pierre sueur on écoute jean pierre bel
et cette séance des questions
d'actualité on se trouve ici ensuite
avec nos invités des derniers de bien
vouloir respecter ce temps pour la
première question la parole est à robert
tropéano pour le groupe rds
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
la décentralisation
madame la ministre vous êtes en charge
de la réforme territoriale voulue par le
président de la république
réforme dans les concours et pas
seulement ceux de la nouvelle carte des
régions sont désormais esquissé et
pourtant bien des interrogations
demeurent aussi bien sur la méthode que
sur le fond oui madame la ministre les
interrogations de notre groupe sont
nombreuses elles sont à la hauteur de
l'incompréhension voire de la
stupéfaction de la quasi totalité des
élus locaux de ce pays toutes tendances
confondues mais aussi de nos concitoyens
car l'enjeu dépasse de très loin les
clivages partisans et les petits calculs
politiques ce dont il est question c'est
de l'avenir de l'organisation
décentralisée de la république initiés
en 1981 par françois mitterrand pierre
moreau et gastoon de faire pour réussir
une grande réforme territoriale doit
s'appuyer sur un large consensus faire
preuve d'une grande cohérence et ses
fondements doivent être claires ces
critères irréprochable et sa finalité
comprise de tous or force est de
constater qu'on a des lois cela commence
mal madame la ministre au regard des
annonces comment est il encore possible
de justifier l'instauration milliards
nang du fameux binôme que les sénateurs
rdse rds se sont fiers de ne pas avoir
voté et qui fait désormais l'objet d'un
rejet massif pourquoi dévitalisées ainsi
vidées de leur substance les conseils
généraux après les avoir rebaptisé
conseils départementaux il y à un aïn
touta recul à la fin 2015 l'élection des
conseillers départementaux dont la seule
véritable mission sera de gérer l'accès
leur propre extension et de fermer la
porte de cette collectivité de proximité
le sentiment d'abandon et fort dans nos
territoires ruraux pensez vous
sérieusement remédier en rattachant
certains départements à des métros pour
le régional situé à une dizaine d'heures
de trajet aller retour
madame la ministre est voix mesure de
nous expliquer de manière argumentée la
fusion de certaines régions et le long
regroupement de certaines autres y at il
là une logique autre que celle de
l'arbitraire du grand marchandage et des
petits arrangements
où il a prise en compte des réalités
géographiques historiques et
sociologiques de notre territoire et
bien que la bretagne est toute simple
intervention française et nous y tenons
pouvez vous illustrer vos propos avec
d'autres exemples alors où est la
cohérence de cette réforme quand il ya
quelques mois vous même vous me
demandiez de rétablir la clause de
compétence générale est que désormais
vous vous apprêtez à nous demander
l'examen posée à savoir sa suppression
a fait madame la ministre pouvait nous
dire à combien s'élèveront les économies
découlant de cette réforme dispose yvon
enfin des chiffres un peu plus fiables
que les annonces de votre secrétaire
d'état
madame la ministre la vrille audience la
vraie réforme c'est le cas tant deux
élus et citoyens n'étaient le passé de
la fiscalité locale et de la péréquation
financière pour établir lisibilité
justice entre les français entre les
territoires je finis monsieur prix merci
d'une démarche de réforme rationnelle et
courageuse et ne plus jouer les élus
contre le peuple car nous savons vous
comme nous qui en sortent ou vont avec
merci la parole et à marylise lebranchu
ministre de la décentralisation de la
fonction publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur robert tropéano je suis pas
étonné de vos propos puisque nous avons
passé ici plusieurs heures
débattre à la fois dans un premier texte
de l'évolution des compétences d'un
certain nombre de collectivités
territoriales de ce que nous pourrions
faire mieux en terme d'intercommunalité
nous avons aussi passé un certain nombre
d'heures à discuter après le rapport de
monsieur raffarin de messieurs raffarin
grattage et des excellents travaux de
madame gouro et c'est vrai que si on
rassemble
l'ensemble
de tous ces travaux et je n'oublie pas
monsieur vélo par exemple vous savez que
nous avons posées ici
une question importante qui était
faut-il faire une réforme territoriale
de l'ordination de notre république nous
avons tous répondu oui bien évidemment à
partir de ce moment là et dès le début
du mois de janvier nous avons eu des
positions divergentes certains
s'appuyant sur les travaux de la
commission balladur disait gardons un
nombre important de région
peu importants pardon de région
supprimant les départements d'autres
s'appuyant sur les travaux de monsieur
raffarin krattinger disant il faut
réduire au maximum le nombre de régions
10 et garder les départements vous savez
très bien monsieur le sénateur qu'il
fallait que le gouvernement prenne une
position à un moment puisque les travaux
avaient commencé en descend que nous
nous étions posé la question ensemble du
devenir des départements avec le
renforcement des intercommunalités qu'au
moment du débat sur la métropole du
grand paris un certain nombre d'entre
vous sur ces bancs c'est pas forcément
les mêmes bancs avaient posé la question
aussi de la disparition des départements
canton les intercomités forte bref
autant de questions posées pouvions nous
continuons à vivre nos rôles à la fois
nous dans l'exécutif sous l'autorité
manuel valls et vous représentants de ce
parlement et en particulier de la haute
assemblée a deux a continué de mois en
mois d'années en années à se poser des
questions à un moment il faut se lancer
dans la réforme le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
décidé deux choses extrêmement
importantes d'une part de réduire le
nombre de régions est le préalable qui a
été posée
rappelez vous monsieur tropéano nous en
avions déjà parlé ici de préalables qui
a été posée par le président de la
république et je parle en regardant le
président de la région bourgogne dans
laquelle j'étais il ya quelques jours
préalable qui a été posé et ses noeuds
découper pas les régions qui ont
ensemble réussi à travailler ensemble à
créer des laboratoires a créé un certain
nombre d'outils bref ne coupons pas les
régions essayons de les laisser
fusionner et ensuite on verra ce que
deviennent les départements le premier
ministre lui même
nom si je peux me permettre de ces
garanties
je ne vais pas refaire le débat que nous
avons eu pendant plusieurs heures en 2
minutes 30 madame la ministre s'il vous
plaît il faut terminer la question je
termine juste que ce président disant
monsieur le premier ministre a tenu à
laisser du temps pour qu'on voie comment
on remplacerait ensuite les départements
merci la parole est à monsieur le
ministre jean pierre raffarin pour le
groupe ump
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministères collèges dans toute la france
la réforme des territoires semble mal
acquis nous avions travaillé ici au
sénat un large consensus afin de nourrir
les travaux de l'acte iii de la
décentralisation il vous est même arrivé
monsieur le premier ministre de faire
référence à ce travail il y avait deux
idées clés dans ce texte dans ce travail
d'abord nous avions proposé d'associer
les territoires selon une approche
réfléchie pour dessiner la nouvelle
carte des régions or nous avons appris
qu'une carte a été improvisée voir
marchander un soir à l'elysée dans leur
solitude
quelques-uns ont imposé le fait du
prince lun lun prôné le repli sur son
territoire ce qui condamne et l'autre à
une opportune solitude
quant à la troisième
refuser à l'ouest rejeté au sud elle ne
pouvait s'accrocher connor monsieur le
premier ministre les identités ne se
négocie pas le lien de la vie et de
l'espace mérite le respect les
réformateurs étaient prêts à discuter
mais le verdict des cartes à briser le
débat
cette méthode plus féodal que
républicaine a sans doute condamné le
projet cette précipitation événementiel
peut-elle s'expliquer autrement que par
des manoeuvres de calendrier électoral
ferdinand broad est le grand penseur de
l'identité de la france nous avait
prévenus l'un sciences sociales a
horreur de l'événement ensuite deuxième
idée à côté des grandes régions nous
proposions de donner un nouvel avenir au
département notre vision était logique
aux grandes régions la puissance et la
stratégie au département la proximité et
la cohésion
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
l'échelon départemental et dans la plus
grande confusion il y à des allers
retours une clarification est nécessaire
votre gouvernement joue gros je crois si
vous videz la proximité de sa substance
au lieu de bâtir l'acte iii de la
décentralisation vous inaugurerait
l'acte 1 de la recentralisation la
réforme territoriale est une question
d'intérêt national qui dépasse je le dis
sincèrement les clivages politiques le
sénat qui par monsieur le président la
constitution aura le premier mot
législatif a toute légitimité pour
s'engager avec ambition dans la réforme
monsieur le premier ministre êtes vous
prêt à faire confiance au sénat et à
faire confiance à l'expérience des
sénateurs
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le premier ministre
notre organisation est devenue trop
complexe
souvent
illisible ce qui n'enlève rien à
l'engagement des élus sur le terrain
mais ce constat tout le monde le connaît
et le reconnaît
ce constat est partagé je n'en doute pas
un seul instant surtout les bons vous
même vous l'avez rappelé sur raffarin
vous avez rédigé un rapport avec votre
collègue qui veut krattinger honorant
ainsi effectivement la place du sénat
dans nos institutions et ce rapport
appelait à une réforme d'ampleur de
notre organisation territoriale et vous
y avez affirmé la nécessité de regrouper
les régions vous l'avez fait
la mission menée par edouard balladur il
ya quelques années faisait aussi ce
constat la formation politique qui vous
intéresse au premier chef elle même sur
son site propose le regroupement autour
d'eux grande région et la suppression
des départements ça veut dire qu'il ya
un débat partout sur tous les bancs sur
tous les territoires et dans toutes les
formations mais ces deux réformes on en
parle mais on ne la fait pas et c'est ce
que nous souhaitons faire c'est de
passer des mots aux actes et sous
l'impulsion du président la république
nous allons le faire je sais bien vous
avez beaucoup d'esprits monsieur le
premier ministre je vous reconnais bien
là mais bon au lieu de s'attarder aux
anecdotes passons à la réalité nous
avons fait nous avons fait je vais y
venir nous avons fait le choix du
mouvement et de la réforme et en
refusant toute réforme constitutionnelle
beaucoup ont aussi privilégié le choix
du statu quo le choix de la posture et
parfois de la caricature je le regrette
et moi je souhaite que notre pays
s'engage sur ce sujet comme sur bien
d'autres dans la voie de la réforme
parce que nous engageons l'avenir du
pays ce pot miss vous avez parlé d' acte
1 de la recentralisation c'est un bon
mot mais c'est faux comment parler de
recentralisation quand nous allons
renforcer le rôle des collectivités
territoriales renforcer la démocratie
locale et faire des territoires les
moteurs du redressement économique
indispensable pour le pays des régions
plus grande avec des compétences
nouvelles des intercommunalités
recalibré est renforcée c'est cela pour
vous la recentralisation non c'est au
contraire donner plus de pouvoir plus de
missions plus de compétences aux régions
et aux intercommunalités parce que nous
savons que c'est le couple qui demain
représente l'avenir pour notre pays deux
projets de loi l'un sur les compétences
l'autre sur le périmètre des régions
seront présentées en conseil des
ministres le 18 juin et ce sont ces
textes qui formeront une réforme
territoriale que je crois cohérente et
ambitieuse vous souhaitez des régions
avec des blocs de compétences renforcées
qui accompagne le développement
économique l'emploi la formation ce sont
des sujets qui vous sont chers eh bien
ces principes nous les mettrons en
oeuvre une telle réforme nécessite du
temps les et si tu viens sur du débat
c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu de nombreuses
consultations ces dernières semaines
président la république a rencontré
toutes les formations politiques
les ministres concernés marylise
lebranchu et andré vallini pour ce qui
me concerne j'ai évidemment fait la même
chose nous avons aussi rencontré tous
les associations d'élus ce débat va se
poursuivre au parlement dès le mois de
juillet à l'automne sur le deuxième
texte et c'est une responsabilité
majeure que vous avez et je ne doute pas
de la capacité du sénat à nous faire des
propositions elles seront examinées
sachez le avec un grand esprit d'écouté
mais si le président la république
n'avait pas fait cette proposition
n'avait pas mis sur la table la carte
n'avait pas indiqué un calendrier et
nous pouvions très honnêtement pas faire
voter nos concitoyens dans un cadre qui
allait être modifié peu de temps avant
déplacer les élections régionales et
départementales de quelques mois pour
permettre la bonne tenue du scrutin dans
de bonnes conditions honnêtement c'est
respecter pleinement le calendrier
électoral et donc le suffrage universel
va s'engager le débat sur le département
et de toute façon pour transférer des
compétences et des agents qui nous
devons beaucoup de respect et de l'
écoute il faut du temps nous devons
expérimentés nous devons adapter j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire ici
puisque l'évolution d'un département
dans une grande métropole ne peut pas
être la même que dans un territoire
rural ou périurbain et nous devons être
attaché notamment aux questions de la
ruralité ce débat il s'ouvre région
intercommunalités place de la commune
département ne faut pas le regarder de
manière frileuse pour le garder avec
l'esprit de la réforme le sénat y
prendra toute sa place et le
gouvernement sera attentif mais en
maintenant évidemment le cap celui de la
réforme indispensable pour le pays
là c'est la parole à mme huguette haut
débit pour le groupe udc
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre en charge du budget
elle concerne la situation d'urgence que
rencontre le secteur de l'emploi à
domicile en 2010 je mettais avec mon
groupe fortement opposés à la
suppression de la réduction de 15 points
de charges patronales liée à la
déclaration aurait elle des salariés à
domicile en 2012 dans le cadre du plfss
pour 2013 j'ai été résolument contre la
suppression du mécanisme de déclaration
au forfait qui avait pour objectif de
renforcer les droits sociaux des
salariés du secteur l'idée était
généreuse mais elle a produit le
contraire de ce que vous en attendiez
les données publiques publié par la qos
sur l'activité des particuliers
employeurs pour les premier et deuxième
trimestre 2013 on était un premier
avertissement
pourtant vous avez rejeté en bloc toutes
nos propositions
aujourd'hui nous sommes face à une
dégradation inédite et inquiétante du
secteur de l'emploi à domicile
ce dernier répond pourtant à des besoins
de vie important garde des jeunes
enfants
accompagnement des parents âgés aides
ménagères et non pas contrairement à ce
qui a été parfois évoqué maître d'hôtel
femme de chambre clowns de goûter ou
coach personnel aujourd'hui tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge sur un an le
nombre de particuliers employeurs à
diminuer de 3,2 pour cent le nombre
d'heures déclarées a chuté de 6,1 pour
cent l'activité des assistantes
maternelles qui jusqu'à présent résister
plutôt bien a reculé de 2,6 pour cent au
total en 2013 ce sont seize mille 500
équivalents temps plein qui ont été
détruits depuis 2011 c'est un énorme
plan social de 40000 emplois qui touche
ce secteur et dont personne ne parle
pour que particulier employeur et
salarié retrouve un véritable intérêt à
déclarer leurs activités il faut poser
un acte fort
est porté à 2 euros la déduction
forfaitaire sur chaque heure travaillée
vous devez nous devons soutenir l'emploi
à domicile au travers d'un vrai
dispositif des aides fiscales et
sociales afin de préserver et de
développer ces emplois non
délocalisables
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre de
nous préciser de nous préciser vos
propositions en ce sens c'est à dire
merci la parole et à christian eckert
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
muguette dini mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie de votre
question qui montre l'attachement que
vous avez sur la situation de l'emploi
dans le secteur des services à la
personne
attention qui est partagé par le
gouvernement ce secteur souffre de trois
phénomènes le premier sans aucun doute
la conjoncture mais il conviendra
d'apprécier précisément cet impact
nous rendrons très prochainement public
les éléments qui permettront d'apprécier
cet impact notamment si l'emploi
direccte particuliers-employeurs connaît
une évolution particulière par rapport à
celui de l'emploi dans les entreprises
services à la personne notamment le
deuxième élément qui perturbe ce secteur
est d'ordre fiscal comme vous l'avez dit
il est d'ordre fiscal tout d'abord à
cause d'une décision vous allez vous
l'avez rappelé de 2011 dire votre
attention sur la date en 2011 une
suppression de 15 points
l'abattement de 15 points sur les
cotisations de bénéficier les
particuliers employeurs a été décidé et
ceci sans réformer les autres
dispositifs d'allégement les
particuliers garder pour autant la
possibilité de choisir de cotiser sur
une assiette forfaitaire égale au smig
et c'était plus avantageux pour les
employeurs mais si c'était plus
avantageux pour les employeurs ça a été
beaucoup moins pour les salariés
puisque ceux ci perdent et des droits
sociaux notamment en matière de
retraites de retraite
ou de droit à indemnités journalières en
cas de maladies
le choix de la majorité précédente a été
cohérent et à
corriger cette situation aberrante en
supprimant la possibilité de
cotiser sur la base du forfait mais le
parlement a souhaité limiter l'impact de
cette suppression de la possibilité du
forfait en créant une déduction
forfaitaire de 75 centimes de cotisation
par heure de travail créé cette
exonération a pesé pour 200 millions
d'euros sur les finances publiques vous
proposait de porter ces déductions à 2
euros à ce stade je peux vous indiquer
que cette majoration aurait un coût de
l'ordre de 300 millions d'euros ce qui
doit conduire à en déterminer avec toute
la rigueur nécessaire
l'impact potentiel nous l'avons annoncé
sur la base du travail d'évaluation que
nous menons et dans le cadre la
discussion parlementaire nous sommes
ouverts à des évolutions puisqu'elles
sont nécessaires pour défendre l'emploi
dans ce secteur ceci comme dans
l'ensemble de ce secteur économique
merci la parole à jean pierre sueur pour
le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre ma question porte sur
la lutte antiterroriste
elle fait suite à l'attentât odieux qui
a eu lieu au musée juif de bruxelles
attentat odieux un attentat est toujours
odieux attentat antisémite
et nous disons notre profonde solidarité
avec tous elles toutes celles et tous
ceux qui sont victimes qui souffrent
aujourd'hui de
l'antisémitisme en france c'est partout
de ces actes barbares
inqualifiable contraire à l'humanité
monsieur le premier ministre les réseaux
jihadistes qui se développe pose de
réels problèmes monsieur le président de
la république vous le savez annoncé
récemment que 30 français étaient morts
en syrie récemment du fait de ces
réseaux
nous savons l'effort qui est menée vous
connaissez ce sujet particulièrement
monsieur le premier ministre je veux
parler des services de renseignement la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
suit cela de très près je tiens à rendre
hommage aux fonctionnaires des services
de renseignement aux policiers aux
gendarmes aux douaniers qui font le
maximum
nous savons que si le maximum est fait
il faut encore agir et nous ne pouvons
nous satisfaire
évidemment de cette situation il faut
faire plus par rapport aux jeunes
avec nos partenaires de l'europe et
d'ailleurs par rapport au réseau
internet il faut prévenir il faut
trouver les moyens pour que cela ne
recommence pas pour empêcher
de tels actes c'est difficile mais c'est
nécessaire
c'est pourquoi je vous demande monsieur
le premier ministre de bien vouloir tout
simplement
dire au sénat les dispositions que vous
envisagez de prendre que vous avez
prises que vous prenez
de manière à faire plus encore pour
lutter contre cette horreur
cette barbarie du terrorisme
merci la parole à monsieur le premier
ministre
le président sur l'interpellation de mai
l'ine mouche confirme dramatiquement
l'actualité et l'ampleur de la menace
terroriste qui menace qui pèse sur nos
démocraties et moi aussi bien sûr à mon
tour je veux m'incliner devant les
victimes de cet acte odieux commis à un
boxell cette menace s'accentue avec
l'expérience de la violence meurtrière
acquis sur les théâtres de combat est
évidemment en syrie
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
ici même
comme ministre de l'intérieur je sais
que ces mots avaient fait débat mais je
pense qu'ils sont plus que jamais
d'actualité
l'ennemi l'ennemi de nos valeurs de
notre démocratie
cet ennemi il est aussi intérieur la loi
de décembre 2012 parce que dès l'été
2012 comme ministre de l'intérieur
j'avais été frappé par la montée en
puissance même si ça ne concernait
qu'une poignée de ces français ou
citoyens résidant en france qui
voulaient se rendre en syrie la loi de
décembre 2012 qui a été voté par une
large majorité ici a permis d'améliorer
nos dispositifs de lutte préventif et
répressif l'accès aux données internet
des cyberjihadistes a été pérennisé dans
notre droit ce qui facilite leur
surveillance mais les actes terroristes
commis par les français à l'étranger
sont punissables dans notre pays mais
j'avais annoncé nous avions tous convenu
d'ailleurs qu'il faudrait sans doute
aller plus loin c'est ce qui a été fait
avec la réforme du renseignement
intérieur et d'enseignement
territoriales applicable depuis le 1er
mai rendre hommage au travail qui a été
fait ici au soutien que j'ai reçus de
votre part la part du président carrère
sur ces dossiers qui rassemble
évidemment sur tous les bancs c'est
également l'objectif du plan lutte
contre la radicalisation violente et les
filières terroristes que bernard
cazeneuve a présenté en conseil des
ministres le 23 avril dernier
évidemment j'avais préparé il prévoit
plusieurs adaptations législatives dont
vous aurez à débattre prochainement et
j'espère le plus vite possible nous
réfléchissons ainsi à la meilleure
manière de compléter l'arsenal pénal
face à certains comportements
individuels et il faudra être sans doute
très ouvert sur ces questions là je
crois qu'il faut s'interdire aucun sujet
conforme évidemment à notre droit notre
constitution
mais se pose même et je veux le dire ici
à la représentation nationale la
question de savoir comment nous traitons
pas uniquement ceux qui reviennent mais
ceux qui veulent se rendre là bas et au
delà des mesures que nous prenons
prévenir et contrarier les départs en
retirant le passeport en interdisant
certains voyages en s'opposant à la
sortie du territoire des mineurs en
combattant et en démantèlement les
filières de recrutement en renforçant la
coopération européenne et internationale
et moi je veux saluer l'initiative de
bernard cazeneuve d'invités joëlle
milquet avec qui nous avions pris toutes
ces initiatives dimanche dernier à paris
en facilitant les investigations des
services sur internet et les réseaux
sociaux en soutenant bien sûr les
familles avec une plateforme nationale
de soutien un programme de réinsertion
parce que la question de la prévention
est tout à fait essentiel mais au-delà
de ces mesures il faut poursuivre
accompagné avec ténacité se pose
évidemment la question du départ je
pense qu'il faut réfléchir très
intelligemment ici il ya suffisamment de
juristes sénateurs qu'ils connaissent
bien ces questions comment on peut ni
travaillant notamment avec les juges
antiterroristes mieux prévenir voire
punir le seul fait de vouloir aller
combattre à l'étranger sujet compliqué
mais sur lequel il va falloir travailler
800 français ou résidents sont
aujourd'hui concernés par les filières
syrienne
490 d'entre eux combattent ont combattu
sur le sol syrien 320 sont recensés sur
place et 30 en effet ils sont morts
140 sont venus de syrie jamais mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs jamais les
services de renseignements n'ont eu à
affronter un tel défi numérique en
matière de terrorisme et donc de suivi
et face à cette menace particulièrement
forte émouvante
il faut s'adapter mais jamais notre pays
n'a eu à faire face à une telle menace
plusieurs filières ou individus ont été
à interpeller ou démantelées je vous
rappelle que nous avons failli connaître
un attentat sur notre sol il y a
quelques semaines à strasbourg ou dans
le sud de la france cette menace elle
est réelle mais nous ne devons pas caché
à nos compatriotes l'étendue de cette
menace et le danger qu'il représente et
nous devons être donc très attentifs
nous mobiliser renforcer la coopération
européenne et internationale et armer
notre
notre paquet législatif pour y faire
face et dans ce cas là je sais monsieur
le président que je peux compter sur la
sagesse et l'esprit de responsabilité
des sénateurs pour appuyer le
gouvernement dans sa lutte c'est une
lutte qui rate doit rassembler non
seulement la représentation nationale
mais tout le pays c'est une lutte qui
doit nous permettre d'éviter surtout
tous les amalgames
je pense à nos compatriotes de
confession musulmane
qui doivent se sentir épaulé par la
communauté nationale car les premières
victimes du terrorisme dans le monde ce
sont les musulmans et nous voyons bien
le dévoiement que représente ce
mouvement mais le danger que cela
représente aussi pour l'unité nationale
de notre pays c'est donc un véritable
défi pour la france et je sais pouvoir
compter sur chacun d'entre vous pour le
combat classique merci la parole un
stern massa pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur qui n'est pas là
son la personne qui le remplace monsieur
le ministre l'antisémitisme en france
que mes collègues l'ont déjà dit et vous
même êtes désormais sur une pente
meurtrière les ententes à de toulouse
puis de bruxelles ont démontré le
protagoniste le navire est l'autre
présumés ont suivi des parcours
similaires sortie prématurée du milieu
scolaire petite délinquance
radicalisation islamique en prison
voyage d'initiation dit rade au
moyen-orient il symbolise le lien couper
avec la société française leur dérive
nous interpelle sur l'école sur les
modalités d'encadrement de nos jeunes
sur ces mouvements de jeunesse qui ne
remplissent plus leur rôle inapte à
pallier la déstructuration du modèle
familial patriarcal duquel sont en
principe issu ses futurs djihadistes en
doc juillet dans la haine du juif et
d'israël au nom de l'islam extrémiste
ingurgité sur internet et gagnant
bientôt lorient où cet endoctrinement se
double de l'apprentissage du terrorisme
si les mesures annoncées hier par le
ministre de l'intérieur au conseil des
ministres nécessaire la question que ces
actes terroristes nous pose n'est pas
seulement d'ordre sécuritaire le
djihadisme new age en france est d'abord
un problème sociétal la prison n'est
devenu le réservoir l'abandon à soi même
la promiscuité aussi la fréquentation de
salafistes fraîchement convertis ils
préparent au pire quand une peine de
probation éviterait à certains le
passage par la case prison pour des
petits délits
la future réforme pénale aidera
peut-être à résoudre au moins cet aspect
des choses le diagnostic sociologique
est imposé les regards actuels de
l'antisémitisme polymorphe ne peuvent
pourtant que raviver chez les juifs et
chez tous les démocrates la mémoire du
génocide qui a un il est six millions
d'entre eux ici même en europe dont 73
mille en france
intolérable cet antisémitisme doit être
combattue par tous les moyens comme
l'islamophobie d'ailleurs la xénophobie
et tous les racismes ces actes
antisémites ne peuvent être amenés à une
affaire entre juifs et musulmans
les arabo musulmans de france un même
pâtissent pas réaction d'une aggravation
du rejet indistinct injuste dont ils
sont déjà victimes en fait ce sont nos
sociétés démocratiques libres
progressiste que ces actes prennent pour
cible et déstabilise monsieur le
ministre les douces les discours
d'apaisement et les messages de
sympathie ne suffisent plus que compte
faire le gouvernement pour changer la
donne en profondeur
et rétablir les conditions d'un vivre
ensemble accès merci merci la parole à
jean marie le guen secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice esther benbassa lorsqu'un
homme entre dans un musée abat
froidement 4 innocent avec pour seul
mobile la haine du peuple juif le
gouvernement et la représentation
nationale sont soulevés comme tous les
citoyens français par l'indignation est
votre question évidemment le souligner
je veux donc à mon tour avec vous
adresser aujourd'hui aux communautés
juives de belgique et de france frappée
par le deuil
et que ces individus au dieu voudrait
condamné à faire vivre dans la peur un
message de soutien
fraternel de solidarité et de compassion
à l'heure où nous rendons hommage aux
victimes il nous faut aussi vous avez
raison madame la sénatrice insisté sur
la dimension de violence extrême qui
s'attache à ces actes et qui doit nous
mobiliser tous au plus profondément des
valeurs de notre société au nom du
gouvernement je tiens à vous assurer
d'abord de notre fermeté absolue dans le
combat que nous livrerons contre ces
menaces en coopération avec nos
partenaires européens dans la lutte
contre cette barbarie moderne les
auteurs d'actes antisémites doivent
savoir qu'ils seront un rassemblement
traquer retrouvés et punis vous l'avez
rappelé le ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve a présenté en conseil
des ministres le 23 juin un arsenal de
mesures destinées à éradiquer la menace
terroriste en france mais vous avez
également raison la ferme mouche
démontre le danger qui peut exister dans
les prisons qui peuvent devenir des
lieux de radicalisation faisant de
petits délinquants les pires terroristes
la prison est indéniablement aujourd'hui
propice à la diffusion du message
radical la fragilité psychologique de
certains détenus la promiscuité favorise
les prosélytisme de tous types c'est
pourquoi le ministère de la justice et
de l'intérieur
prépare une série de mesures ambitieuses
visant à renforcer l'action des services
de renseignement pénitentiaire à
améliorer le recrutement et la formation
des aumôniers notamment musulmans et
bien évidemment les tentatives d'
amalgame qui sont faites autour de la
religion musulmane sont inacceptables
car nous savons très bien que ces
terroristes travestissent la nature de
cette religion enfin que ces homos sied
soit des imams formés aux principes
cilic et citoyens qui sont ceux de
l'islam de france il s'agit enfin de
prendre en charge les individus
radicalisés
au terme de leur détention mais vous
avez raison madame la sénatrice de
signaler qu'au delà de ces aspects de
surveillance et de répression il existe
un combat permanent à mener dans la
société tout entière et il y a
évidemment les questions posées par les
technologies modernes internet il y a
aussi tout simplement la résurgence de
propagande et il y a quelques mois les
affaires dieudonné nous rappeler
l'engagement du gouvernement dans ce
sens voilà madame la sénatrice au moment
où nous pouvons considérer que cette
situation est très grave la volonté du
gouvernement qui s'exprime par un combat
tout à fait déterminé et globale contre
l'antisémitisme contre la violence et
contrôler terrorisme merci la parole un
christian favier pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues là ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la
décentralisation et la fonction publique
vous allez proposer dans quelques jours
dans la provision la plus totale une
réforme territoriale dont personne ne
veut hormis peut-être quelques cercles
libéraux de m
cette réforme imposée par le président
de la république ne procèderons le ced
aucune règle ne s'appuie sur aucune
étude d'impact ni objectifs clairement
définis
loin de toute concertation véritable et
en concentrant les pouvoirs locaux cette
réforme est contraire à l'engagement 54
du candidat hollande qui visait à
associer les élus locaux pour promouvoir
une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation
il s'agit en fait aujourd'hui d'un
bouleversement considérable de nos
institutions locales qui va voir la
disparition des communes au profit nada
communalité d'au moins vingt mille
habitants qui vont organiser la fin
programmée des départements
même si cela est contraire à notre
constitution qui va regrouper nos
régions et réduire le nombre des élus
locaux et tout cela accompagné d'une
cure d'austérité sans précédent pour
toutes les collectivités pour justifier
l'urgence de ce big bang de nos
institutions l'argument avancé reposait
sur d'importantes économies espérées or
maintenant votre secrétaire d'état en
charge de cette réforme déclare qu'il
faudra attendre cinq à dix ans pour voir
le débutde économies éventuelles en fait
il n'ya effectivement aucune économie
réelle à espérer de cette réforme si ce
n'est en réduisant l'action locale la
réponse aux besoins et aux attentes des
populations
il ya donc aucune urgence à mettre en
oeuvre cette réforme il serait
inacceptable d'avoir un débat
parlementaire tronquée à la hussarde en
procédure accélérée durant les vacances
al'inverse nous vous demandons
d'organiser un grand débat national
associant la population et en respectant
le rôle des assemblées élues nous vous
demandons de consulter l'ensemble des
assemblées départementales et régionales
nous demandons que le scénar réunissent
à nouveau les états généraux pour donner
la parole à tous les élus locaux et que
cette parole soit réellement entendu
enfin comme 58% des français nous vous
demandons qu'à la suite de cette vaste
consultation le projet adopté par le
parlement soit soumis au peuple
souverain qui seule est habilitée à
transformer le cadre institutionnel de
nos institutions merci madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur jean favier je connais votre
attachement au territoire j'ai pu le
constater avec vous sur le terrain
et je voulais simplement faire des
remarques suite aux propos du premier
ministre tout à l'heure nous avons
beaucoup discuté ici est pris tout notre
temps pour parler des territoires de la
terre comme l'a été je sais que sur le
sujet de l'intercommunalité
nous n'avons pas trouvé d'accord je
pense que nous n'en trouvons pas mais
quand vous dites tout ça à était fait
trop vite on a passé plusieurs semaines
à faire ce débat je vous rappelle
je vous rappelle je vous rappelle je
sais pas qui crie comme ça
c'est vrai on ne peut pas savoir qui
crie dans son dos je vous rappelle que
le président de la république a tenu
après avoir posé les principes des
fusions de région le 14 janvier après le
débat du sénat à prendre en compte
l'avis de tous les groupes politiques
représentés au parlement ce qu'il a fait
pendant plusieurs mois le premier
ministre a rencontré tous les
associations d'élus responsables et
maintenant il faut que nous passions un
moment que nous rentrions dans le vif du
sujet avec deux textes celui dont a
parlé monsieur le premier ministre tout
à l'heure sur la réorganisation
territoriale à partir de la carte des
régions et puis ensuite bien que ces
deux textes soient présentés ensemble
vous l'avez remarqué nous continuerons à
discuter des compétences je vous
rappelle qu'ici nous avons beaucoup
progressé entre la première mouture et
la fin de nos débats il y a maintenant
quelques mois nous avons à prendre des
décisions ensemble concernant en
particulier la compétence des acteurs
comme unités et celles des régions leur
rôle dans le redressement économique du
pays nul ne pense que le territoire en
l'état ont suffisamment de moyens en
terme de masse critique et de délais
mende mais ne criez pas comme ça
et en termes d'échangés interne pour
pouvoir redresser le pays preuve en est
c'est qu'il ya
pardon alors je vais vous regardez le
ministre continue et s'il vous plaît on
pourrait jouer à tout vous savez
nous avons ici un débat extrêmement
intéressant et je dis aussi grâce à la
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales sur le rôle des
collectivités territoriales dans le
redressement du pays et je vois que
certains nous approuve ce débat a été
riche il a été fourni vous n'avez pas
compter votre temps nous n'avons pas
compté le nôtre elle ne ne compteront
pas notre temps pour continuer à
discuter des compétences et de la
meilleure façon de rendre ce qui
n'existe pas sur les territoires de
france aujourd'hui c'est l'égalité en
territoire et même l'équité aujourd'hui
il y perd richesse côtoient lippert
pauvreté cela ne nous satisfait pas nous
voulons aussi retrouver la solidarité
entre les territoires merci la parole
est à monsieur le président gérard
larcher pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre et dames et messieurs
les ministres mon interrogation
rejoint celle du président sueur et de
madame benbassa elles montrent l'émotion
qui traverse tous nos groupes face à la
tragédie qui a été vécu au musée juif de
bruxelles qui vient nous rappeler la
tragédie de toulouse mais aussi une
tragédie qui a frappé nos soldats je le
rappelle avant toulouse et des familles
et bien sûr nous vivons cette solidarité
fraternelle avec la communauté israélite
mais ces cribles démonte que dans
d'autres pays l'obscurantisme en gras
une certain esprit et peut ronger
progressivement notre socle républicain
cet islamisme radical le président
d'honneur du conseil français du culte
musulman mohammed moussaoui s'en est dit
récemment très préoccupé et je le cite
ce phénomène de radicalisation qui
défigurent l'image de l'islam et des
musulmans
chaque français quelle que soit son
appartenance religieuse ou philosophique
doit pouvoir vivre en sécurité et
liberté
c'est cela la france la x et cela
s'applique aussi à ceux que nous
accueillons
depuis des années plusieurs centaines de
jeunes rejoignent des mouvements
jihadistes
comment prévenir ces départs je sais
monsieur le premier ministre que ceux-ci
préoccupe le gouvernement
comment gérer aussi les retours d'hommes
et parfois de femmes entraîné ayant vécu
dans une certaine ambiance quelles
seront leurs objectifs oui au retour
face à ce terrorisme djihadiste la
réponse doit être globale et européennes
le coordonnateur européen contre le
terrorisme d'ailleurs l'a rappelé à
l'intérieur et au delà de l'espace
schengen les actions d'europol
d'eurojust de frontex doivent être mieux
coordonnées il ya quelques semaines nous
étions avec une délégation du sénat à
sanliurfa à la frontière de la série
nous avons vu à la fois l'accueil de
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés syriens
en turquie
ça allait dire dans cette horrible
guerre le liban connaît la même
situation mais en même temps nous avons
vu la présence de mouvements extrémistes
tels que l'état islamique en irak et où
le vent dont se réclame mehdi des
mouches alors monsieur le premier
ministre je sais que 25 juin devrait
être présenté en conseil des ministres
un plan qui va compléter le premier plan
présenté à l'heureux quatre
interrogations
de quels moyens humains financiers
juridiques disposons nous pour
surveiller suivre ces individus
dangereux je vous ai entendu tout à
l'heure évoqué le renforcement de ses
moyens privation de passeport que
l'interrogation expulsions d'étrangers
impliqué dans les filières djihadistes
cyberpatrouille gel des avoirs du micro
filière voilà me semble-t-il quelques
éléments comment optimiser l'action d'un
dg ici comment surveiller ces jeunes
dont l'enrôlement commence sur le web se
poursuit parfois mais pas toujours en
prison car le problème de la prison
n'est pas le seul problème faut-il
renforcer la coordination de l'action du
bureau de l'administration pénitentiaire
enfin je sais que le président de la
république dans le cas du g7 hier a
évoqué cette question avec les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement je sais que le
ministre de l'intérieur le fait
aujourd'hui même vraiment j'allais dire
nous tous quel que soit notre
sensibilité il nous semble que la
réponse ne doit pas être qu'une réponse
de circonstance face à un drame mais une
réponse globale car il y va aussi des
valeurs républicaines ainsi la parole à
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
président larcher
votre question les pistes les réponses
l'esprit qui vous anime rejoignent à la
fois les questions qui ont déjà été
posées et les réponses que le
gouvernement à porter c'est un
sujet de préoccupation majeur et qui
concerne tous les pays
dans les initiatives que j'avais prises
communiste l'intérieur que développe
amplifie bernard cazeneuve il était en
effet il est au luxembourg dans le cadre
d'une réunion avec les ministres de
l'intérieur européens nous avons décidé
d'amplifier la coopération avec d'autres
pays qui sont concernés par ces
phénomènes de pays comme les etats-unis
l'australie le canada qui connaissent
les mêmes types de problèmes mais aussi
évidemment d'autres pays voisins comme
la jordanie et le liban mais aussi le
maroc ou la tunisie qui connaissent de
quelle manière également ses départs
vers la syrie donc c'est un arsenal de
mesures niveaux international européen
bernard cazeneuve comme la ministre de
l'intérieur belge l'ont souligné cela
pose toutes les problématiques de
fonctionnement l'espace schengen le
suivi la coopération entre les services
cela veut bien dire dans ce domaine là
comme dans bien d'autres qu'il faut
davantage d'europe est en tout cas
d'efficacité sur ce sujet comme sur bien
d'autres et puis il ya notre propre
arsenal qu'il faut renforcer
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure a été créée précisément pour
faire face à ce type de problème mais
aussi son lien sa coordination et le
renseignement territoriales car il faut
être capable de détecter tous les
signaux faibles comme on dit dans le
jargon du renseignement pourquoi parce
que nous ne faisons pas face à une
menace organisé classique comme celle
que nous avons pu connaître par le passé
mais à une menace diffuse dans la
société au sein même de la société
française et ce phénomène nous les
connaissons dans d'autres pays en grande
bretagne en belgique dans les pays du
nord de l'europe en espagne en allemagne
aussi un niveau jamais connu donc
l'échangé d'expérience mais aussi la
capacité de prévention le travail en
prison mais vous avez eu raison monsieur
le président le dit qu'il n'ya pas que
la prison caprioli un travail qui est
entamée déjà depuis plusieurs mois jean
marie le guen le rappelait grâce à la
coopération entre le ministère de la
justice et celui de l'intérieur mais
l'auto radicalisation sur internet pose
des problèmes majeurs et dans le
dialogue que nous avons avec nos amis
américains leur faisons valoir ça vaut
pour le terrorisme comme ça vaut là
aussi pour d'autres secteurs les
contraindre les contradictions les
empêchements du à l'amendement un de
leur constitution qu'ils empêchent
d'aller plus loin les questions liées à
la liberté de la presse nous en avions
débattu ici même à l'automne 2012 ces
problèmes il faut les poser sans avoir à
l'esprit vous l'avez dit aussi et je
vous rejoins des textes de lois ou des
mesures de circonstances mais qui
répondent à cette menace majeure pour
notre démocratie et pour la cohésion ça
vous l'indiquiez avec vos mots pour la
cohésion de notre pays et nous devons
éveillé et nous devons ensemble trouver
à chaque fois la bonne réponse celle de
la société et vous avez raison de
rappeler
les mots de l'ancien président du
conseil du culte français musulman et je
veux saluer aussi l'initiative qui a été
prise par le recteur de la mosquée de
paris parce que c'est une mobilisation
du culte musulman des intellectuels
musulmans de toute la société pour faire
face à ce qui peut devenir une fracture
dans notre pays et puis trouver bonne
réponse législative juridiques qui
doivent s'imposer nous y reviendrons
très vite parce que là il faut aussi
agir vite avec beaucoup de précision en
tout cas c'est le président merci du ton
et du soutien que vous apportez à une
cause qui évidemment dépasse tous les
clivages et qui doit nous rassembler
merci la parole à gilbert enjeu pour le
groupe socialiste
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur michel sapin
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics
monsieur le ministre ces dernières
années beaucoup de français modestes
sont entrés dans l'impôt alors que leur
situation n'a pas évolué en 4 ans le gel
du barème de l'impôt sur le revenu la
suppression de la demi part fiscale des
personnes seules ayant élevé un enfant
ont poussé près de 4 millions de foyers
notamment de petits retraités dans
l'assiette de l'impôt sur le revenu
cette situation n'est plus soutenable
pour les contribuables en particulier
du bas du barème aussi je salue la
décision prise par monsieur le premier
ministre
de réduire ou d'annuler l'impôt sur le
revenu des personnes gagnant moins de
200 euros nets par mois cette mesure
bénéficiera à plus de 3 millions de
ménages et parmi eux 1,8 millions ne
seront plus soumis à l'impôt sur le
revenu la taxe d'habitation et la
redevance télé éteinte assise sur le
revenu fiscal de référence ces
contribuables n'acquitteront pas non
plus ces taxes qui se déclenche
automatiquement
avec l'entrée dans l'impôt sur le revenu
bercy a mis à disposition des
contribuables un simulateur sur internet
pour connaître le montant de l'impôt
déclaré aussi beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ayant utilisé cet outil de
calcul pour connaître le montant de leur
impôt en 2014 et certains ont pu
constater une forte augmentation parfois
700 euros par rapport à l'année
précédente
le problème est que le simulateur ne
prend pas en compte l'annnonce de la
réduction d'impôt prévue dès septembre
2014 puisque cette mesure n'a pas encore
été voté par le parlement elle sera dans
quelques jours et quelques semaines
aussi monsieur le ministre pourriez vous
organiser une communication
direction de chaque foyer concerné par
cette réforme afin d'indiquer à ses
contribuables que la simulation faite
sur internet ne correspond pas du tout à
ce qu'ils vont payer à l'automne puisque
la réduction d'impôt s'appliquera dès le
mois de septembre 2014 je vous remercie
pour votre réponse précise et claire
merci sous le sapin ministres des
finances et des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gilbert roger
comme vous le savez dans le pacte de
responsabilité et de solidarité
le gouvernement a décidé de vous
proposer de proposer à votre vote un
certain nombre de dispositions qui vont
permettre d'une part de diminuer des
cotisations ou des impôts qui pèsent sur
les entreprises ont leur permettent
d'investir et d'embaucher mais va
permettre aussi et en 2015 de manière
massive de baisser les cotisations
pesant sur les salariés et de faire
sortir vous venez d'en parler de l'impôt
sur le revenu les couples le plus
modestes qui sont rentrés au cours de
ces dernières années ou qui risquerait
d'y rentrer à cet automne 2014 cette
rentrée la conséquence d'un solde de
mesures votées par les uns comme par les
autres dont par exemple la fameuse demi
par des veuves nous entendons parler à
chaque fois qui a été votée il ya de
nombreuses années et dont les effets
néfastes continue encore aujourd'hui à
se faire sentir sur un certain nombre de
personnes âgées nous avons donc décidé
de vous proposer de proposer à votre
vote une mesure qui permettra de réduire
l'impôt de 350 euros pour un célibataire
ou de 700 euros pour un couple
dès lors que ce célibataire ou le couple
de fois plus gagnerait qu'ils soient
retraités ou qu'ils soient salariés un
peu moins en moins de 1,1 smic ce sont
près de plus de 1 million 800 mille
foyers qui vont ainsi pouvoir comme vous
disiez vous même sortir de l'impôt sur
les revenus avec toutes les conséquences
que ceux-ci emporte en termes de baisses
d'autres types d'impôts ou de baisses
d'autres types de contributions comment
ce système sera-t-il finance et vous le
savez là aussi le gouvernement vous
propose de financer cette diminution est
même parfois suppression de l'impôt pour
les plus modestes des français en
mobilisant les revenus nouveaux qui ont
été en quelque sorte provoquée par la
régularisation des comptes gratuits et
des comptes en suisse c'est l'argent de
ceux qui ont caché leur argent qui va
nous permettre de baisser l'impôt des
plus modestes des français alors vous
dit à juste titre comment cette
information va-t-elle pouvoir être porté
à la connaissance de ceux qui sont
concernés puisque nous ne pouvons pas
nous ne pouvions pas nous ne pouvons pas
décider de mettre dans nos dispositifs
d'information des dispositions qui n'ont
pas encore été voté par le parlement
cependant monsieur le député monsieur le
sénateur nous avons décidé de mettre
d'ici à la fin de ce mois un nouveau
simulateur à blanc qui intégrera ces
réductions et permettra à chacun de
connaître exactement la situation qui
sera la sienne
c'est une bonne nouvelle dont chacun
pourra prendre connaissance
merci la parole à yves daudigny pour le
groupe socialiste
non pardon
pardon pardon on va inverser la parole
est un rené paul savary pour le groupe
ump avec toutes les excuses
je trop vite
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame le ministre en charge
de la famille des personnes âgées et de
l'autonomie elle porte sur la dépendance
elle annonce faite hier en conseil des
ministres de l'acte 2 de l'apa
allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie
cela ne vous a pas échappé madame le
ministre que les terrains n'étaient
toujours pas compensé financièrement aux
conseils généraux en effet la pas et
sous la responsabilité des départements
depuis sa création il ya une dizaine
d'années et cet échelon départemental a
fait preuve d'efficacité
l'âge moyen d'entrée en maison de
retraite a reculé de 75 ans à 83 ans
c'est une avancée majeure en faveur du
maintien à domicile et du bien-être des
personnes âgées c'est incontestable est
largement reconnue et cela malgré toutes
les difficultés budgétaires le projet de
loi madame la ministre parle parle d'une
revalorisation porte sur 645 millions
d'euros financés par la case à la
contribution additionnelle de solidarité
pour l'autonomie payés par les retraités
eux-mêmes et place où je dirais plutôt
placé les départements comme chef de
file de cette prestation
véritable reconnaissance de leur savoir
faire je suis sûr madame le ministre que
vous ne souhaitez pas brouiller les
pistes entre réforme territoriale
politique de la dépendance et son
financement alors vous allez donc
pouvoir je pense répondre clairement à
mes questions
la première à la place des départements
qui vont être
dévitalisées aux dires de certains
attanasio didot dire d'autre quel
échelon sera reconnue pour assurer cette
prestation ou bien envisagez-vous une
recentralisation du dispositif deuxième
question quel calendrier avez-vous
retenu pour sa mise en oeuvre la
question n'est pas anodine puisque la
casa est perçue depuis l'an dernier et
troisième question enfin pourquoi cette
recette n'est-elle pas attribué dès à
présent au département permettant ainsi
de réduire le reste à charge pour les
usagers merci merci madame le ministre
pour vos précisions car le
vieillissement concerne ou concernera
tous nos concitoyens et même chacun
d'entre nous mes chers collègues même si
comme disait andré malraux on le voit
vieillir que les autres merci la parole
à laurence rossignol
secrétaire d'état chargée de la famille
des personnes âgées et de l'autonomie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur savary merci de cette question
en effet le gouvernement
adopté en conseil des ministres mardi un
important projet de loi sur l'adaptation
de société au vieillissement est en
effet ce sont 640 millions d'euros qui
dès la promulgation de cette loi seront
consacrés à l'accompagnement du
vieillissement
c'est à dire à la fois l'anticipation du
vieillissement parce que les nos
concitoyens veulent vieillir le plus
longtemps possible dans les meilleures
conditions chez eux à l'adaptation notre
société au vieillissement et en
particulier l'adaptation des logements
et du cadre urbain au vieillissement de
la population parce que vieillir chez
soi ne signifie pas rester chez soi et
enfin un volet important consacré à
l'accompagnement dont je dirais avant de
vous répondre sur la question spécifique
de l'apa pourrait signaler une mesure
extrêmement importante qui est celle de
la mise en place d'une aide aux aidants
d'un droit au répit qui permettra aux
familles qui accompagnent des personnes
âgées en grande perte d'autonomie de
pouvoir pendant quelques jours par an
pour prendre une semaine de repos de
financer un hébergement temporaire c'est
donc une loi extrêmement importante et
vous nous interroger sur son financement
le financement vous le connaissez c'est
effectivement la casa qui va être dès la
promulgation de la loi disait
intégralement consacrée au financement
de la loi accompagnant de vieillissement
et je voudrais vous rassurer les
conseils généraux n'auront pas à prendre
en charge une quelconque dépenses
supplémentaires la loi prévoit en effet
que les personnes en perte d'autonomie
recevront à la fois plus d'heures dead à
domicile et que le reste à charge qui
l'aurait laissée pour le moment sera
réduit c'est donc une mesure
d'accompagnement est une mesure de
justice sociale extrêmement importante
que et que cette prise en charge sera
totalement assumée par la casa je crois
donc pouvoir vous avoir répondu en
partie à vos interrogations en ce qui
concerne le calendrier en ski au sein de
calendrier l'examen en première lecture
viendra le plus rapidement possible et
ensuite si le parlement travaille vite
comme nous souhaitons tous et je pense
que sur son projet doit nous pouvons
tous nous retrouver pour montrer au pays
que nous sommes unis face aux grands
défis c'est quoi pour être pourra être
le plus rapidement possible à la portée
de tous les français merci yves daudigny
pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues en octobre
dernier ici même à l'ouverture des
débats sur le projet de loi garantissant
l'avenir et la justice des retraites
j'avais tenu à souligner à la tribune
combien trois ans après une réforme
passer en force nous allions changer de
méthodes de projet et de perspectives la
loi promulguée en janvier 2014 créées
des doigts droit nouveau c'est une
réforme de justice et de progrès il
suffit de rappeler outre la prise en
compte de la pénibilité ce qui n'est pas
le moins l'amélioration du dispositif de
retraite progressive pour les seniors et
de retraite anticipée pour les personnes
handicapées celle des travailleurs
précaires avec l'abaissement du seuil
d'acquisition d'un prime est de 200 à
150 heures smic la validation des
périodes d'apprentissage et de stages
pour les jeunes l'augmentation des
pensions des non salariés agricoles le
droit à une majoration d'assurance pour
les aidants familiaux la volonté et
l'action du gouvernement se sont aussi
inscrits dans un contexte d'inégalités
entre hommes et femmes dans la sphère
professionnelle et dans la vie
quotidienne des familles madame la
secrétaire d'état vous étiez alors
rapporteur de la délégation aux droits
des femmes je ne vous apprendrai donc en
rien en rappelant le constat que vous
portiez vous même sur l'importance des
droits familiaux qui compense en partie
l'écart des pensions endroit propre
entre hommes et femmes précisément de 58
à 72% la délégation demandé à cet égard
que les droits familiaux soient centrées
sur la maternité pour remplir l'objectif
de compensation de ses conséquences sur
la retraite des femmes le décret publié
le 1er juin dernier qui permettra enfin
titre est un quotidien de prendre en
compte la durée réelle des congés de
maternité pour les droits à la retraite
s'inscrit me semble-t-il dans cette
perspective de compensations madame la
secrétaire d'état je vous remercie d'en
donner confirmation à la représentation
nationale et de nous éclairer sur les
conséquences concrètes de ce nouveau
droit merci madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur yves daudigny merci
de cette question et merci d'avoir
souligné que la loi sur les retraites
n'a pas simplement garantie dans la
durée le financement des régimes de
retraite mais qu'elle a aussi permis à
l'initiative du gouvernement et avec un
soutien fort de la majorité
parlementaire d avancée sociale majeure
parmi ces avancées sociales majeures
vous l'évoquiez il y à celles qui vont
dans le sens de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes en effet
aujourd'hui la retraite des femmes est
en moyenne de 30% inférieure à celle des
hommes ce qui est proprement
inacceptable
bien entendu l'égalité des retraites se
joue bien avant l'arrivée à la retraite
elle se joue dans les parcours
professionnels et il faut se battre tout
au long de la vie professionnelle des
femmes aussi bien un code du travail que
dans les plans d'égalité professionnelle
pour leur garantir des carrières égale à
celle des hommes et il est assez égale
un gars important que la conciliation
entre la vie familiale et la vie
professionnelle qui est souvent
l'obstacle plus lourd qui pèse sur les
carrières des femmes soit favoriser
ainsi la mesure que vous avez révélé et
qui vient de faire l'objet d'un décret
est importante soixante dix mille femmes
vont pouvoir compter sur des trimestres
supplémentaires au moment du calcul de
leur retraite lorsqu'elles ont eu trois
enfants et plus ou par exemple des
jumeaux ou encore pour celles qui ont
adopté cette mesure importante s'ajoute
à d'autres qui figure dans la loi sur
les retraites et qui vont permettre une
meilleure prise en compte du travail à
temps partiel lequel je vous le rappel
touche principalement les femmes et il
peut être principalement le montant des
retraites des femmes je rappelle aussi
la double valorisation revalorisation du
minimum vieillesse cette année soit 80
euros de plus pour les petites retraites
sachant que celles-ci sont perçus à 80%
par les femmes vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur le gouvernement oeuvre en
faveur de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes au moment de la retraite au
travail et dans la vie quotidienne merci
philippe darniche pour le groupe des non
inscrits
merci monsieur le président le seul
premier ministre
parti je crois mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
mes chers collègues en septembre comme
d'autres collègues ici présent je ne
briguerait pas un nouveau mandat de
sénateur à l'aune de cette étape
politique je regarde derrière moi
taraudé par cette question quel monde
sommes-nous en train de transmettre à
nos enfants
alors permettez moi de poser la question
quelle société voulez vous transmettre
aux générations de demain
depuis plusieurs décennies je voit
s'écrouler les repères qui ont façonné
ma vie
je pense à mon éducation familiale je
pense à ces liens de fidélité qui ont
permis de construire une famille je
pense à cette société qui accueillait
les petits et protéger les faibles et
nos aînés de génération en génération
aujourd'hui je constate que le
gouvernement remet en cause la nature
rien de plus rien de moins avec les abcd
de l'égalité par exemple votre obsession
de déconstruire les stéréotypes
revient à déconstruire la
complémentarité
la différence hommes-femmes vous ne
l'acceptez pas car vous ne concevez pas
que le mot complémentarité puisse
exprimer respect et enrichissement cette
complémentarité devait rester la
référence dans le mariage entre domaine
femmes et dans l'éducation et
transmettent à leurs enfants
on doit aimer la vie on doit aimer
respecter nos anciens car ils sont la
pierre sur laquelle s'est construite
notre histoire
ça c'est le devoir filial on de
s'émouvoir devant le malade l'handicaper
car dans son corps blessé c'est notre
humanité qu'il porte et pourtant que
faites vous lorsque
96% des foetus porteur d'une 13e d'une
trisomie 21 sont avortés au seul
prétexte de leur maladie pourquoi avoir
dissocier avortement et détresse
pourquoi avoir rendu gratuite la pilule
contraceptive pour les jeunes filles des
quinze ans vous les déresponsabiliser en
leur faisant croire que dans la vie la
liberté c'est assouvir tous les désirs
alors même que ses désirs peuvent vous
rendre esclave de quelle liberté parlez
vous quand nos aînés touché par le poids
des ans
quand nos concitoyens malades centres
risquent de se voir supprimer par une
société quitte bouleverse les codes
multiséculaire de l'accompagnement de
fin de vie que faire dans ce monde qui
ne respectent plus les lois écrites
inscrits dans le coeur de l'homme d'une
manière générale le bateau france part à
la dérive chaque jour des indicateurs le
démontrent les français désorienté se
réfugient dans les extrêmes face à
l'augmentation du chômage vous fait
diversion et proposer un projet de
réforme territoriale bac d sans aucune
concertation face à l'explosion de la
sécurité vous ne trouvez rien de mieux
qu'une loi favorisant le laxisme pénal
les générations futures ne peuvent pas
être sacrifiés
je m'adresse au gouvernement dans son
anti dans son ensemble qu'ils ont c'est
ce rêve ou d'abîmer la france
merci madame laurence rossignol
monsieur c'est un temps derniers d'abord
peut-être je voudrais contribuer à lever
en vous une inquiétude qui me paraît
importante est lourde probablement
d'abord essayer de vous rassurer non les
androgynes ne vont pas revenir et ils ne
vont pas de nouveau provoqué la colère
des dieux est déclenché et celle de zeus
vivait tranquille non la différenciation
des sexes ne nous menace pas elle ne
menace pas l'espèce humaine cette peur
ancestrale qui est historique et qui est
absolument identique à celle de peur de
la fin de l'espèce d'une espèce qui
cesseraient de se reproduire faute de
fautes de reconnaître sont plus et sont
moins monsieur le sénateur ce qui marque
l'humanisme l'humanisme moderne c'est
justement la conviction que la nature
est tout sauf une norme morale une norme
morale est ce qui fait la force de la
république celle que les hommes ont
construites qui sont allés conquérir sur
la nature qui ne leur avait pas donné
c'est que justement elle permet à chacun
de vivre selon ses convictions et la
force de la loi civile c'est qu'elle ce
qu'elle permet elle ne l'obligent pas
donc pour tout ce que vous évoquez
personne n'est obligé mais la loi des
hommes le permet la loi de la nature
l'interdît vous nous demandez monsieur
le sénateur quelle société nous voulons
transmettre à nos enfants et bien une
société construite sur les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres qui sont celles de cette
maison c'est là où je les ai consolider
ou bocoum on me les ont enseigné aussi
celles de la république de la liberté
l'égalité et de la fraternité
car ce sont les seules valeurs
universelles et c'est elle qui nous ont
permis à nous les femmes en particulier
de conquérir des libertés nouvelles que
la nature ne nous avait pas donné non
plus je pense au premier rang duquel les
droits procréatif la contraception le
droit à l'ivg et j'ai qui je le rappelle
avant la loi veil exposait des centaines
de femmes à des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse dans des
conditions inhumaines dangereuse et
mortels ces droits-là la nature des
aides nous a pas donné mais parfois même
elle était tellement généreuse que la
nature était un fardeau pour nous
monsieur sénateur je vous souhaite une
retraite heureuse vous aurez le temps de
vous consacrer à des controverses la
place de la fois la place de la loi et
une vieille question posée par les
apôtres est ce que la loi de dieu est
supérieure à celle des hommes ou est ce
que la loi des hommes est supérieure à
celle de dieu bonne retraite de sénateur
merci merci mes chers collègues nous en
avons fini avec des questions
d'actualité
je vais suspendre la séance l'ordre du
jour du mardi 10 juin 2014 à 14h30 débat
quel avenir pour les colonies de
vacances à 17h débat sur l'application
de la loi du 21 août 2007 sur le
dialogue social et la continuité du
service public dans les transports
terrestres réguliers de voyageurs et à
21h30 débat sur les collectivités
locales et la culture la séance est
levée
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité que vous avez pu suivre en
direct du sénat on se retrouve tout de
suite avec nos invités pour refaire
ensemble la séance ans
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct cet après-midi du sénat après
la séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement séance dominé vous avez pu
le constater cet après-midi par la
réforme territoriale qui intéresse
évidemment beaucoup nos sénateurs jean
marie le guen